[Musique]
pamela participer à danse avec les stars
se passer et je pense qu'on est obligé
de se faire un petit assiste à un petit
à petit danse avec pamela
franchement est-ce que qui a très envie
de danser avec pamela mathieu mathieu et
pamela m'amener dire pamela venait avec
moi est ce que vous pouvez faire
venez avec moi bien mathieu attention
madame venez là on va mettre une musique
un peu difficile de danser dans le sable
oui alors venez l'armée della valle là
c'est plus facile mais là c'est là que
je vis ma tu as très envie de danser
avec vous et jean-michel dansera avec
bois près aussi oui à michel il a très
envie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
il avait alors on va voir
pamela va dire qu'ils dansent le mieux
jean michel maire
[Applaudissements]
répétez pas avec l'autre cache bien
attention du sel musique ça veut dire
[Applaudissements]
l'e mail est dégueulasse pamela il est
nul non non non génial comme des
parasites
je veux la mort je veux d'abord benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un gars
arrête de pleurer
[Applaudissements]
tu la touche moi
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
la même attention
[Musique]
vous avez parlé du coup je me sens et je
pense que je suis base annexes vont
mettre une musique orientale
ça me rappelle salle sur la tête de ma
mère à chaque fois que je suis en gt en
boîte à fait à même à avant d'être connu
à chaque fois qu'ils avaient une musique
orientale
tous les gars et soulèvement as pour toi
c'est moi qui m'étais diarra la seule à
ton père ou dj alors attendez avant
qu'on danse j'aimerais juste mon sens un
petit kiff caroline et paris là ça c'est
pour le kiff
alors on l'aimé pas mais là mais on peut
se dépêcher non mais ça va pas
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci bien rattrapé la secte a vécu un
cauchemar allait peu merci pamela qui
quitta la qui est le mieux dans ces
mafieux chinoise infotel s'est pas c'est
pas lui c'est elle c'est
[Applaudissements]